[Music]
[Applause]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
and to a crisis that has preached two
great british institutions
the bbc and the royal family into a
confrontation
that could change both for good when
princess steiner spoke to the bbc's
martin bashir 25 years ago
none of the watching millions could
mistake her anger
we now know that the interview was
obtained by deceit
and her son the future king says that it
was the bbc's
lies which led to her bitterness mr
bashir now says that he
is deeply sorry but the bbc faces yet
more questions not least because for 25
years its bosses
knowingly covered up bashir's lies
and then gave him a new job
in just a moment we'll be speaking to
the home secretary pretty patel
her labour shadow nick thomas simmons
joins us from
cardiff princess diana's most famous
and authorized biographer andrew morton
tells us what he thinks was in the
princess's mind
and we'll ask one of britain's most
revered tv journalists
former head of news and current affairs
at channel 4 dorothy byrne
whether the corporation can ever rebuild
trust
and finally as if he could ever be and
and finally
i'll be speaking to jeremy corbyn's
shadow chancellor john mcdonnell
about what labor needs to do to compete
again
first up the home secretary pretty patel
good morning home secretary thank you
for joining us uh before we turn to the
announcements that you want to make on
immigration
can we spend a moment on the revelations
about the bbc
lord dyson the duke of cambridge the
duke of sussex
and now many of the bbc's young
journalists have called the national
broadcasters
integrity into question do you
personally trust the bbc
well i think it's important to recognize
um the
criticism and the deep concern
associated with the report that was
published by lord dayton
the bbc itself one of our great
institutions its reputation has been
compromised it's being questioned right
now
and they themselves will have to reflect
upon the report and spend a great deal
of time
i think um really looking at how they
can regain and rebuild
trust and confidence confidence and
trust of the british public
but also they are a world-class
institution so
they will have a great deal of work to
do in this particular area
and of course right now it's a very very
important time for the bbc to very much
look at itself and learn some very
important and significant lessons post
the publication of this report
but the word i'm not hearing in answer
to my question do you
personally trust the bbc is yes
can you say yes well absolutely at this
stage
we are focused and even from a personal
perspective i'm very conscious of
the hurt the damage that this report has
highlighted
and on that basis trevor you've already
heard me say i think the reputation of
the bbc has been compromised there's no
question about that
trust and confidence has been undermined
and now is the time for the bbc
to absolutely reflect upon the findings
of this report and rebuild that trust
and confidence
i'm hearing a note there and i'm
wondering if what that means is that
you think that the bbc cannot go on
marking its own
homework after jimmy savile after cliff
richard now after
this thing do you think
like for example lord grade that we need
some way new way of holding the
corporation to account for example he's
proposed
a new board of uh editorial policy
uh composed of experienced
independent journalists well i think um
there will be a review point um trevor
next year
is an opportunity when it comes to the
midterm review of the
bbc charter for government and the bbc
to absolutely look at
new ways of governance of the
institution the organization that is the
bbc
so my colleagues i know the culture
secretary in particular
will be working with the bbc to very
much use that moment as an opportunity
and i say this as an opportunity
to review governance and accountability
structures
and post this report that's going to be
a very very important moment
some of this does come into your
wheelhouse doesn't it the metropolitan
police
are saying that though they looked at
this in march
the dyson report has caused them to look
at the
situation again do you rule out the
possibility
of criminal prosecutions well trevor
it's not for me at this
early stage to even speculate and
comment on anything of that nature
clearly investigations if they are
taking place you know that has to go
through the process
but fundamentally right now i come back
to very much from a government
perspective
there will be an opportunity
specifically on the governance of the
bbc
where there will be an opportunity not
only for reflection but an opportunity
to
look at governance reforms and how
effectively accountability and
governance can be strengthened
there will be a very very significant
moment now there's no question about
this
where lessons have to be learned yes
within the bbc itself
yes with the leadership of the bbc it's
journalists
and people that work for the bbc too but
ultimately
the governance and accountability that
ultimately would lead to
public trust public confidence in the
way in which the bbc operates and the
way in which it conducts its business
but you talk about this being an early
moment and i
understand that but what i'd take you to
be saying
to the metropolitan police and its boss
cressida dick
that if they find a reason
to proceed with any criminal
prosecutions
there will be no pushback from the home
office if that is their judgment
well look i'm not trevor it's not for me
to even contemplate or speculate
um anything in that i'm not asking you
to speculate i'm absolutely asking you
i was i'm simply asking you to confirm
what you've already said i think
well i think it's important right now to
reflect upon
findings of the report and any other
information
that comes out that is associated
specifically with what has happened
and of course you know if there is
subsequent action that needs to be taken
then clearly
alongside the publication of this report
lessons being learned
and changes changes to the institution
structure
governance accountability then that will
follow from a government perspective i
should just emphasize again obviously
there'll be a midterm review of the
charter next year
and my colleagues in government will
absolutely ensure that that is used
as the right opportunity not just for
reflection but to enhance governance and
accountability within the bbc
okay the bbc is unnoticed let's just
have a quick word if i may
on uh the vaccine situation public
health england say this morning that the
vaccines we're using in britain are
effective against the indian variant
is that news that means that we can look
forward
to reopening on june the 21st well i
think trevor we should all
really just look look at the success of
the vaccine
program and how that is gradually
enabling us
all to live our lives the reopening of
society
unlocking of aspects of our economy
clearly that's
exactly what the roadmap is all about
and the prime minister himself is being
clear
that there are key tests and key stages
in the run-up to the 21st of june
we will always continue to look at the
data when it comes to the next stage of
the roadmap that is sensible
that is responsible and i think we
should absolutely just reflect upon the
success of the vaccine
and how that is giving people
individuals society
businesses confidence to be back out
there again
what is a very critical time you know a
year
after lockdown and very tough decisions
that have been made by the government
so um maybe two cheers uh across the
nation for that let's uh
turn to an area for which you are
directly responsible and that is
immigration
you and the prime minister regularly
remind us
that we now have control of our own
borders
so why are you planning to spend time
and resource on
new legislation well these are important
changes trevor
around the uk's approach to immigration
and it is correct the prime minister
rightly
and i speak about this is absolutely
part of our manifesto commitments
to take back control of our borders and
we've done that by ending free movement
that was part of leaving the eu but also
introducing a new points base a british
points based immigration system
that's one important aspect of legal
migration
dealing with legal migration and how we
have our rules in place
how we also support the brightest and
the best to come to the united kingdom
to
bolster our economy and support
businesses in terms of their own
economic growth
what i'm unveiling and proposing
tomorrow is a new legal migration and
border strategy
which very much sets the framework for
the future which is based upon
digitalization of our borders
but also the simplification of our
immigration laws
currently thus far we've already
simplified something like 21 in
i understand why you're focusing on
simplification and technology
and so on and so forth but in what way
will new electronic gates at airports
stop
boats crossing the channel to kent
or people hiding in lorries well there
are two
so trevor there are two points to make
here first of all digitalization is
absolutely
important because we can upstream checks
we can do checks on individuals before
they even arrive in our country
and that's important in terms of foreign
presenting themselves to be checked
i will come on to that in a minute i'm
also when it comes to illegal migration
so the digitalization is speaking about
legal immigration
illegal migration is a very very
important problem and issue for our
country it has been
an issue for decades and decades whether
it's a back of lorries or people
crossing the channel in very very
dangerous circumstances being
facilitated by
criminal gangs and people smugglers i am
introducing the new borders bill which
will come to parliament next month
where we will specifically clamp down
and tackle
the problems around illegal migration we
are going to change our laws
we will have not just greater checks
we've already got very very significant
law enforcement
operations taking a place in france in
belgium
upstream and we're already prosecuting
and arresting the people smugglers last
wednesday
i myself saw a number of arrests of
people that had been trafficking and
facilitating people
but the key the key point to make trevor
is that when it comes to claiming asylum
and we are going to change our asylum
laws and our asylum system because it's
broken
people that are being smuggled they
should be claiming asylum
in a safe country the first safe country
that they travel through
more often not these are eu member
states rather than taking the risk of
coming to the united kingdom
and so we are going to be proposing
legislation i've made the announcements
already
we've published our new plan for
immigration which tackles this very
issue
illegal migration trafficking okay
home secretary let's get this in in
perspective uh
since the beginning of the year uh i
think that you
have deported something like 700
foreign criminals but according to the
pew research
organization there are something like
800 000 to a million
undocumented migrants in this country
and that i think is probably what most
people are worried about how you deal
with that and the proposals you make
don't
uh don't address that at all and let's
take a case in point
ten days ago in glasgow
uh the borders uh agency
border force attempted to remove two
indian men
uh from pollock shield because they'd
overstayed their visas
a large crowd gathered they blocked the
road
completely peacefully by the way i
should say and in the end the border
force
gave up and the men are still here what
are you going to do about that
well trevor you're exactly making the
case as to why we need to reform our
immigration
reform has nothing to do with this it
actually does
so the reforms i'm proposing cover
illegal legal migration and
illegal migration so you mentioned for
example the number of people foreign
national offenders these are
high harm criminals people that have
committed all sorts of atrocities
against british citizens in the united
kingdom
we will continue to remove those
individuals and in fact
many of the part of the proposals that i
am bringing forward
will make it easier for us to remove
foreign national offenders
so we will stream so if i may tell me
what you're going to do about the two
gentlemen in pollock street
i will in just a minute so we will also
be changing many of the appeals
processes where individuals
go to court again and again and again to
thwart our ability
as a government to remove high harm
individuals
or people that have overstayed their
right to be in the country or who have
come to the united kingdom illegally
so immigration enforcement and not
border force it's immigration
enforcement in glasgow
they were stopped from removing two
people that had no
legal basis to be in the united kingdom
they were doing their job
the protesters stopped that from
happening in terms of the removing
those two individuals there is a whole
process around the removal of people
that should not be in this country
um at all people that are here illegally
we will continue to strengthen our laws
to enable the government to remove
people with no legal basis to be here
national offenders and criminals you're
going to have
another go at re removing these
gentlemen
um what do you think the first minister
is going to say because in 10 days ago
she tweeted the home office needs to ask
itself hard questions after today doing
this on eid in the heart of our muslim
community and in the midst of a serious
coveted outbreak
was staggeringly irresponsible but the
even deeper problem
is an appalling asylum immigration
policy are you going to confront nicola
sturgeon on this question
well the point about our immigration
policy immigration is a reserve matter
for the government here and quite
frankly it's pretty clear that when it
comes to
the nationalists in scotland they would
much rather have an immigration policy
of open borders
no checks when it comes to criminals
coming to the uk
and no border controls and i think
actually her comments
also reflect upon the nationalist
position when it comes to
removing people that have no legal basis
to be in the uk
this is nothing to do with with eid
at all immigration enforcement
absolutely doing their job doing their
job
in terms of removing people with no
legal basis to be in the uk
i think it's absolutely sorry a sorry
state of affairs that we see the
nationalists in scotland
basically trying to thwart the safety
and security
off the british public but also trying
to prevent the british government from
removing those with no legal basis to be
in the uni
united kingdom this is trevor exactly
the reason why we are changing our laws
and bringing in new legislation so that
the government can remove
people that should not be in our country
while protecting the safety and security
of british citizens
through the legal routes and the
digitalization that i'm proposing
i look forward to returning to this with
you uh home secretary before we finish
can i
briefly return to a topic that's very
much in your
on your entry and that is the windrush
compensation scheme
where the home office has reported that
21 individuals have died before their
cases
could be processed you also
predicted that you should have paid out
at least 120 million pounds
to victims of this scandal by the end of
march this year
in fact you've only paid out around 14
million pounds do you feel in any way
ashamed at the way your department has
treated these people
well i think first of all trevor when it
comes to the windrush scandal
and it was a scandal there is a very
very significant report published by
wendy williams and
based on the lessons learned from that
scandal we're actually implementing the
recommendations from wendy and the
changes
that were that she put forward and that
report came out last march i've been
clear to
my department that those reforms are
coming they're in place
but you specifically asked about the
compensation scheme now
it is what i asked about was how you
felt did you feel ashamed about
what has happened windrush scandal has
been an absolute stain quite frankly
on our country but also on what has
happened in the home office i've been
very public about that and
i will reiterate that and i'll restate
that but it doesn't mean that we ignore
what has happened so there's been a a
whole range of changes that have taken
place
but you specifically asked about
compensation now first of all the
compensation scheme was designed in
consultation
with members of the windrush community
and the generation
themselves members of that generation in
december
so just five months ago because the
scheme was simply
too slow and complicated in terms of
bringing forward
payments i overhauled the scheme so in
the last five months
we have seen over 26 million
26 million pounds of payments um being
put out
but also at the same time in march less
than two months ago
we had our highest month where eight
million pounds of compensation was paid
out now the changes to the scheme have
been brought in place in conjunction
with the windrush stakeholder advisory
group and i do actually want to thank
everybody
because these are members of the
community that worked with me
and with my the department to find
faster ways of streamlining payments and
getting money out but trevor there is
a lot more work to do here there really
is i've been very vocal about this and
it's right that we work
night and day to fix not just the
compensation and get the money out but
also many of the problems
people involved in the actual scandal i
i get that home secretary
and i hope we will have more
opportunities to talk
about this again thank you very much for
your time this morning
now labor has described the government's
record on immigration as devoid of
compassion
and utterly chaotic let's see if the
shadow home secretary can tell us what
labour would do
that is different and better here
is the shadow home factory nick thomas
simmons in
cardiff um nick thomas simmons
you never stop criticizing the
government for their failures what
objection could you possibly have
to an effort to make the removal of
foreign
national offenders quicker and more
effective
well clearly people who've no right to
be
in this country shouldn't be here but
what we've seen
from the home office is utter
incompetence on this and let me just
take
an example as well we talk about the
asylum system the government keeps
saying the asylum system
is broken they've been in power for 11
years and they
broke it if you look at 2014 87
of asylum claims are being dealt with
within six months
that figure had fallen to 20 percent by
2019 and what did the government do
they got rid of performance targets and
what we
don't want to see is the government
deflecting blame
for their own failure when it is their
compete in confidence
their management and mismanagement of
the home office that's been the problem
so so let's so labour's solution to
people coming ashore
uh on the beaches of kent is that uh
there should be performance
targets for civil servants there should
be
uh performance targets in the asylum
system but in terms of
the issue of both programs they're going
to win the boats as they're coming
ashore no
no hang on in terms of the english
channel
in my view the government needs to look
at a number of measures
firstly the long promised agreement with
france that needs to be effective and it
needs to be fully published made
available to us all
that's first and that's a priority for
the government
secondly the government needs to revisit
its decision to abolish the department
for international development the very
department that existed
to prevent people being driven from
their homes in the first place the very
department
department that was trying to deal with
you know the the issues that come from
war
poverty and persecution thirdly the
government needs to look
at the issue of safe routes for example
they
close down the dub scheme the dub scheme
which everyone in parliament expected
expected to take in 3 000
unaccompanied child refugees was closed
down prematurely after 300.
that's the kind of approach the
government needs to be taken because
none of us want to see people making
these
dangerous crossings across the channel
okay let's let's let's deal with a real
world situation
i asked the home secretary about the two
men in glasgow and she's pretty clear
um you know she's pretty hard line on
this they're going they're going to go
what would labour do look
as a general principle people who
shouldn't
be in this country people who shouldn't
be here absolutely yes they have to be
removed with this particular situation
in glasgow
i don't know in terms of the particular
circumstances of it i'm not sure the due
process
has been observed the home office
doesn't have a great track record on
that i'm afraid i think something like
55
of a cl asylum claim succeed on appeal
so i think there has to be that
guarantee on due process and second
the whole method of immigration
enforcement
by the use of dawn raids is something
the government has to seriously
reconsider
because that particular method of
enforcement isn't something clearly that
is building the confidence right across
the community that we need to
with respect mr thomas simmons what
you're telling me is why
everybody why the government isn't doing
its job what i'd like to know
is what would you do if it is
demonstrated
that these gentlemen should be removed
because they have overstayed
would you as she has promised to do be
sending
the immigration enforcement uh people
back in
if if it is shown the due process has
been fully followed and people aren't
entitled to stay whether it's the
two men in glasgow indeed anywhere else
then yes of course they should be
removed but the point i'm making trevor
around enforcement
is that the particular method of
enforcement that's being used here which
is this sort of
dawn raid system that's being used is
not a method of enforcement that is
gaining
any kind of confidence from the
community there are better ways of doing
things
but people who are not entitled to be
here yes they should be removed
okay um big story today the bbc
what do you think that the bbc the
national broadcaster
has to do to restore the public's trust
and in particular the public who fund it
well fundamentally the bbc now needs to
show
that what happened with the martin
bashir
interview couldn't happen again that
obtaining of an interview
by deception and we've seen the the
impact
that's had on the royal family have you
heard princess william and harry talk
very
movingly about the impact that that has
had and then very understandably now
that's raised very wide questions
about ethics and about how that can be
prevented from happening again i think
there's a specific question
too as to how the bbc came to once again
employing mr bashir in 2016 and how that
happened
but look the bbc makes some some great
programs
the bbc still has a great reputation
around the world but it now has to
rebuild trust
and prove to people that what happened
then
couldn't happen again now but um do you
think
you know making strictly and
attenborough documentaries makes up for
lying to princess diana do you think
that the bbc has run out of road and
that
now now it can't continue marking its
own homework which is really the
question today
well look certainly making great
programs certainly doesn't make up in
any sense
for what's happened here what's happened
here certainly
has to be dealt with now there has been
a change in governance
structure since back then in those days
of course you've had the board of
governors who
you know guarded as of course too close
to the management at the time and there
is this
different structure that it exists now
uh there is of course but what we need
to see from the bbc now is quite openly
to tell us
what it is in the structure that now
exists that's different that would stop
that from happening and what they're
going to do now
to rebuild that trust thank you very
much dick thomas simmons from
cardiff now andrew morton is
the journalist that the princess of
wales hand-picked
to reveal her disillusion with royal
life
she even gave him a nickname noah short
for noted author and historian
his 1992 book diana her true story
revealed her deep unhappiness with her
marriage
few people knew her mind better and he
says that when bbc reporter martin
bashir walked into her world
he changed it forever but not
for better good morning
andrew you were the person who in a way
started this
entire chain of events with your book
what did you make of martin bashir's
interview in the sunday science this
morning
in which he said i never wanted to harm
diana in any way and i don't believe
we did
well when i first watched the interview
back in 1995
it was like watching the tv version of
diana her true story
so bashir used duplicitous means to get
diana to sit down
in in her sitting room and give the
interview but she was the one who owned
what she had to say
so an awful lot of what she did say had
been circulating before that
but because it came out of her mouth it
seemed sensational raw and new
do you think that she would have done
this interview
anyway with somebody somewhere
if she hadn't done it with martin bashir
yeah
oh absolutely there's a queue a mile
long outside kensington palace oprah
winfrey barbara walters
clive james david frost um the bbc had
their own man nicholas witchell who
had two meetings with her and then
bashir swooped in and said
i've got uh contacts with earl spencer
we're
looking down a different road and his
boss said
stan stand back so there's no question
at
all that diana was going to speak her
mind i think there may be an allegedly
in there somewhere andrew but
but i think that the central point i i
really wanted to get at is
would he have got this interview if he
had not lied or would it have gone
somewhere else
uh he wouldn't have got it it's as
simple as that he scared her half to
death
he he had her thinking that he had
contacts inside mi5 he was very
plausible
he arranged meetings in underground car
parks
scary places at the best of times but
when you think that your life is in
danger it was it was
very potent so she was she was put in a
state of fear and trepidation
um and that encouraged her to speak out
and she
and so when she gave the interview it
wasn't a question of self-indulgence as
many people thought
but it was a question of self
preservation she thought that she was a
target
she thought that what from what bashir
said she was
she was uh um under the gun
or in the in the sights of the
establishment and remember
she'd lived like this for most of her
adult life
so in a way you're lining up with the
the duke of cambridge here because
prince william
said last week it is my view that the
deceitful way the interview was obtained
substantially influenced what my mother
said the interview was a major
contribution to making my parents
relationship
worse and has since hurt countless
others
and his brother said the ripple effect
of a culture of exploitation
and unethical practices ultimately took
her life i mean in a sense
what all three of you appear to be
saying is
that the manner in which martin bashir
got this provoked a kind of
i think the word has been used as
paranoia in the princess
that meant that what she then said uh
was
reflected that fear
now i i i disagree with william and
harry on this
and and i do find it ironic that it's a
bunch of
old etonians uh including earl spencer
who think there's a line between
the interview and diana's death i mean
diana wanted to speak her truth
and and she'd been stifled for a long
time
so yes she was she was terrified into
doing the interview by bashir
but no well what she had to say was
very much reflected what you really
truly felt three of us in the marriage
queen of people's hearts all these
things that she would have probably said
these kinds of things to somebody else
uh nicholas whitchloss
some other uh journalist it so happened
that bashir
beat the pack by lying to her and that's
how he did it
where do you think this leaves relations
between the royal family and the bbc
well relations between the bbc and the
royal family were
at an all-time low after the panorama
interview they
they uh really turned their backs on
them and they've been rebuilt over the
years
now of course when you've got these
extraordinary public statements given by
uh prince william and prince harry are
attacking the bbc then they've got a
long way to go to restore that trust
you're a distinguished journalist andrew
um
how does what's been revealed by
this scandal leave you feeling
about our trade
well we this is
this is the phone tapping moment for the
bbc and remember
the news of the world was involved in
tapping
uh harry and william's phones and that
that newspaper was shut down
this this is a a black day for for
british journalism
and i think that we should all reflect
on
how you obtain an interview and the
process by which
you carry it forwards the bbc's
phone tapping moment thank you very much
andrew morton
the bbc has been publicly and furiously
excoriated by the heir to the throne
and is being warned by ministers that
they will intervene if it doesn't do
enough to restore
trust with the public we did ask the bbc
to appear on this program but they have
chosen not to
so let's bring in dorothy byrne former
head of news and current affairs
at channel 4. dorothy burn you were one
of the
most senior executives in british tv
journalism at channel 4 for many years
and in fact it was channel 4's
documentary last october that started
questions being asked about this whole
affair once again
how serious is this for the corporation
do you think and can it recover
i think it's extremely serious what has
been revealed
is absolutely scandalous
and it is scandalous that for more than
25 years the bbc has refused to
fess up to what it did when in fact
all other television journalists have
known
about the faking of these bank
statements
for more than a quarter of a century
it's also
scandalous that martin bashir was
employed just a few years ago
ironically as head of religion so it is
extremely serious
and actually we as other television
journalists
are outraged because it has
led some people to smear the whole of
our profession
when in fact television journalism
overwhelmingly
is very tightly regulated
and not at all the way that tabloid
journalism
behaves since the events
26 years ago the bbc has become
regulated independently and i think
that is absolutely key uh
at the time the bbc was permitted to
regulate itself which was
clearly absolutely wrong so
i think it's very serious but we
shouldn't
see this as an opportunity
to attack all television journalism
however i do
think that the bbc itv
and us networks need to look
at all the other stories which martin
bashir did
sorry say that again you're saying we
need to go back
over martin bashir's record through
bbc he's worked for uh itv i think he
may have worked for channel 4
and a couple of the new us networks and
we need to look at
all he's done yes i
do not believe martin bashir ever worked
for channel 4 i would never have
employed martin that
year i knew all about him many questions
well i didn't know all about him i knew
some about him
many knew enough about him to say that
if if he'd come to you for a job
you would have shown him the door he
wouldn't even have got to the door
he's one of the most notorious
journalists in britain
and has been for a quarter of a century
i mean
it would be almost funny that the bbc
had employed him as head of religion if
it wasn't
so obscene but other people who have
been
interviewed by michael by um
martin bashir have complained
that he lied to them and
we know that the bbc wrote a formal
letter to
itv about martin bashir's conduct
on several stories so i think that
both bbc and itv need to look at all his
scoops
because what martin bashir and some of
those around him
did was mistake getting a scoop at all
costs for proper decent ethical
journalism
dorothy let me put this to you um
you are pretty uh robust about
martin bashir's record martin bashir
might say
if he were watching this well of course
they'd say that
they didn't get the story so of course
they're going to try to bury me
martin bashir can say that if he wants
i would rather not have a story
than get a story by lying
proper investigative journalism
should never be confused
with lying to get a scoop a scoop is not
the be-all and end-all of journalism
that's uh if i may say a terribly male
attitude towards journalism you know
journalism is about careful and forensic
investigation of the type that we saw in
the panorama
uh last week which exposed martin bashir
i i yes one looked at that interview and
thought it's amazing that he got that
interview
but that's actually one of the problems
with martin bashir
on several occasions other journalists
have thought
how on earth did he get that scoop how
on earth did he persuade that person to
do that interview
and that is what we must now
see investigated dorothy
this story is really just uh in part
about
martin bashir the bigger issue i guess
is about the bbc
do you think the time has come for the
bbc to stop
being able to mark its own homework
well the bbc no longer marks its own
homework
in the way that it did more than 25
years ago
it's now properly regulated by ofcom
and i think that ofcom is a good
regulator
and from all over the world people come
to the united kingdom
to look at our system of regulation
because it is so good and it's because
it's so
good that we have very high levels
of trust in british television
journalism and particularly
during this pandemic we've seen
ofcom itself has revealed these figures
very high even higher than usual
levels of trust in television journalism
so we we mustn't assume
that the public doesn't trust
journalists
it is worth pointing out though that
those very offcom figures that you're
quoting
put uh the bbc at the bottom of the
trust league
uh 10 points behind sky eight point
behind your own channel
four do you think that
this system of regulation though
has been shown to be at best
inadequate do you give any credence to
the proposals
for example from lord gray that there
should be an editorial board
of experienced journalists who can spot
the signs of this kind of thing going on
which
you know the bbc's board of governors
the best will in the world full of
people who don't do journalism
would never be able to see
at the time that this happened the bbc
was regulating itself it is now
quite recently moved to a new system
where it is regulated in the same way
that the rest of us
are the idea that yet another committee
of so-called experienced blokes is going
to
make some difference i i don't have
any i don't give much credit to the idea
that the problem with men is more men
i i think that the regulator that we now
have
is good i do think that one reason
that the bbc has fallen
just slightly in these tables of trust
is the relentless attack on it in
newspapers
which i think would affect people's
attitudes towards it
but i've never worked for the bbc i've
never wanted to work for the bbc
i've always regarded it as an arrogant
organization of post-white blokes
and that's what we saw happen in that
um in this scandal how
those men covered the traces
but it is a very good organization
and the journalists are good you you you
will
be familiar with the uh phrase
that it's not the crime that's that
really killed you but it's the cover-up
and i wonder your equivalent uh at the
bbc
who later became director general tony
hall
uh did what dyson
has described as a pretty weak and
feeble investigation
what do you imagine was going through
the minds of bbc
management when they allowed this to
happen
how could do you think having been at
that level of responsibility
how do you think this actually took
place
i i cannot see into the mind of that man
i think there is a great arrogance there
isn't there in that institution
certainly at the time
that they thought they didn't need to be
transparent
you know there's a moment when you
discover something bad has happened in
your organization
and you need to gird your loins and
and face up to it it's happened to me in
my career that
bad things have happened in the
organization and
what you have to do is admit it
there's an arrogance about the fact that
the bbc didn't admit it at the time
and i think that was partly the culture
and that there were too many similar
types of people overwhelmingly men
running that
organization and it shows me that we
need
greater diversity in the higher
management of organizations
in our country the bbc's got a new boss
tim davey who was responsible for
publishing this dyson report um what
would he
need to do to satisfy you that the bbc
has done enough
to make sure that nothing like this
and i include the cover-up by the way
could happen
again for me
it's important that the bbc
should also inquire into how
martin bashir ever came to be
the head of religion and it's important
to me that they should look at the other
stories that he did at the bbc
and they should cooperate fully with
ofcom
when they receive complaints i think
they do
uh they do behave better now indeed i
recently made a complaint
tim davey myself about the bbc and he
responded
wow uh well i bet he's uh pretty
terrified after this
thank you very much dorothy burton thank
you
following humiliation in hartlepool
labour will choose its candidate for the
by-election in badly and spend today
senior figures on both the left and the
right have publicly called for sakia
stammer to resign
if they lose and at least one big beast
labor's
king of the north andy burnham has
reluctantly let everyone know
that if called upon he is ready to serve
i'm joined now by the former shadow
chancellor john mcdonald
john mcdonnell let's get one thing out
of the way first if we might
um jeremy corbyn is still a
member of the labour party and a member
of parliament but he is not a labour mp
because kirstama removed the whip is it
time for him to be readmitted to the
parliamentary labour party
yes it is it is kyo when he was elected
leader
said that um he'd unite the party and
that's why he received such overwhelming
support when he was elected leader
and one step in demonstrating his unite
in the party is to
give jeremy back the whip i think most
of us can't believe that
he had the whip withdrawn in the first
place when he was allowed to be a party
member so yeah
i think it would be a i think it'd be a
really helpful act if care did that now
do you think it would genuinely unite
the party i mean
do you think that someone would be some
some of the members of parliament
who have accused um jeremy corbyn of
enabling anti-semitism
might feel bit too soon don't you think
well i think it would be one for small
step
in uniting the party and i actually do
think now is the time to move on and
jeremy is look he's a labour party
member
he's had no disciplinary action taken
against him so
there's nothing holding back therefore
in having the labour whip restored so
i just think it's time to move on now
and it would be just
one small step of of care saying look
that i'm fulfilling the promise i gave
to party members of uniting the party
all right well let's look at the future
your friend and colleague diane abbott
um
said this week kier starmer faces
another by-election in the coming months
in battley and spend
if labor loses again it must surely be
curtains
for him i imagine you agree don't you
well i i followed the tony ben line you
know which it's about policies not
personalities and
i think you can add to that it's also
about the narrative as well so
the issue isn't about care it's about
the future of the labour party and what
we have to do now is
i am going to come through policy john i
am going to come to policy john but
come on yeah i've known you as a
straight shooter for many many years you
don't duck questions
do you agree with diane or not i don't
get into the personality issue i never
do
and i actually always work on the basis
that
we should have a political debate about
the direction of the party
and that should never rest upon one
individual
one person this is about the whole of
our movement that's why i never get
dragged into that sort of thing but but
diane's point is not about whether
kia star was nice or nasty the question
is whether he can
win for labor and put you back into
power to do
the things that you're about to tell me
you want to do so
i'll try one more time do you agree with
that that goes back that if
if he loses at battery that is a clear
signal
that the best service he could provide
for the party
is to step down so it always gets back
to the political program it never
is about individuals this is an issue
the whole movement
has got to face about how we go forward
and what political program that we can
turn the fortunes of the party around
upon and give the labour party actually
and the country a sense of purpose it's
never down to an individual that's why
exactly like tony benn i never get
dragged into comments about individuals
it's about
the movement as a whole all right well
your colleague in the movement the
deputy leader angela
rainer did go to the issue of labour's
program and what she says is nobody
knows what it is
she said that on the doorstep uh
people did not know what kier stammer
stood for let's take the personality out
of it
but what she's saying is nobody knows
what the labour party is about
right but well that was a valid
criticism
it was a valid criticism when kier got
elected leader he did
say yes i'll unite the party and he did
set out a basic 10-point
program and that doesn't seem to be
where he's at at the moment so the
message to
the party overall is that you can't go
on the doorstep of fighting elections
and then
when people you can criticize the
government but then when people
ask the question well what would you do
you haven't got an answer so the key
issue for us now
is consolidating where we go forward how
we're going to give the labour party a
sense of purpose again how we're going
to give the country
a sense of purpose again and what kier
said when he was elected leader
is that he'd use the last manifestos as
the sort of foundational documents
upon which to build upon no one expects
him to follow slavishly past policies of
course you don't
in fact the past policies now i think we
do need to
radicalize them and go further so
therefore we should be having we should
have had it already but we should
be having now the policy debate about
where we go forward
what's our policy program what's the
narrative what's the
vision of the society that we want to
create care's now launched a policy
review so
that's going to be the focal point for
that debate so at least now we're moving
towards it i
just think i know we've been tied down
with the covid pandemic but
the last 12 months should have been used
to that effect you know
even in the second world war there's
lots of references that even johnson
makes the second world war
even during the second world war at our
lowest point
progressives and socialists were
dreaming and discussing
and planning the society that we want to
create that's what we should have been
doing
that's what we need to do now indeed so
let's let's come to that john because
what i think you've just told me is that
what labor now has to do
is to come up with a program that is
even more left-wing
than the one it put forward in 2019.
so let's you you've got you you've
traveled trevor
listen to my words let me finish my
question let me finish the question
you're going to advise kirsten what are
the top three things that you're going
to say
care these are things that the people
need to know
that labour stands for okay trevor
sophie ridge set a very good high
standard for this program i think you
should stick to that standard
what i said was let let's let's not
let's not get away
what i said well let me just say to you
when you when you interview someone
don't put words in their mouth what i
said a more radical program you can
interpret that as left or right or
whatever
the key the reason we need to be more
radical is because we're facing in this
country an existential crisis
of climate change we're coming through
covert hopefully
and we're coming through clovid but
we're still faced with the same problems
of grotesque levels of inequality and
poverty we've seen today
that last year more billionaires were
made in this country
than in the last 30 years and yet in my
constituency and elsewhere
we have a family struggling just to make
sure they can put food on the
plates for their children low pay
insecure
work lack of housing public services
underinvested
even our public servants who saved lives
during this crisis
are now faced either with a pay freeze
or a paid cut but the existential
threat to climate change is what we have
to face up to now
that's the next big crisis that we face
so what i'd be saying to him of course
we have to tackle
immediately these problems of inequality
low pay
insecurity poverty in our society but
recognize
rushing towards us now is the threat of
climate change and that means just
dramatic and radical change in our
economy and the way in which we live
in the interest of keeping up the high
standard of journalism this program
i've let you set out what you think the
problem is what i really are what i
asked you before
was what are the things that you will
advise the party leader
to be labour's policies that will define
labor okay name one immediate
okay let's go through them immediate
action now to tackle poverty
that means a fair taxation system where
we redistribute wealth in this country
full stop that's it secondly making sure
that when people go to work they own a
decent wage and that means yes a pay
rise for the nurses
the 15 percent ending the pay freezes
restoring trade union rights
and then the green new deal to tackle
climb a green new deal to tackle climate
change
they're the three elements that i want
to see now that we actually
provide the basics so that people have a
decent quality of life
they can be properly paid they have a
reasonable income a roof over their
heads
put food on the on the plates and so
they can feed their children all of that
but above all else
a green new deal now to tackle the
climate change threat
do you think that the vision that you're
putting forward which involves
more spending and you know let's be
clear
left right more radical whatever you
call it you've been you've been pretty
clear which is one of the things that i
think
people most admire about you do you
think there's a problem for labor
the tories have borrowed billions and
they're running into
running a huge deficit they're promoting
the policy that you put forward
2019 on on broadband this week by the
way they nationalize the rail
network uh do you think that there's a
problem
that for the lay party that um boris
johnson's
standing a bit to the left of kierstama
right now
what we've got to do is cut through the
rhetoric of the tories
and look at the substance take rail for
example this isn't nationalization
what they're doing is they're leaving
the rail in private hands so it can be
so profits can go to the pro private
sector
but all the risks flow then to the
public sector so it's not the plans that
we put forward certainly in fact
it looks as though we're going to be
ripped off even more by these private
companies
but again look at the levels of
investment that they're talking about
they can no longer argue that we can't
afford it they can no longer argue that
the resources aren't available
because when we're in the covi crisis we
found the resources
we're now facing the biggest crisis ever
the threat to
our very existence so if the resources
need to be found
they will be found and you know that's
what's happening right the way across
the world look at what
biden is doing in america he's finding
the resources he's bringing forward a
plan
to tackle climate change and the other
policy you know that we should get on
board with
is the biden policy of making sure that
the whole world the whole
globe is vaccinated so we take on the
big pharmaceutical companies
make sure that they no longer using
patents and
the other forms of legal devices to
prevent the technology and information
going to the global south those are the
sort of purposes now that we should be
swinging behind
and you know this country could lead on
many of these things
john incredibly bold i hope we'll be
talking more about
these policies in times to come thank
you very much for joining us
thanks a lot that's it for now
after the break we'll be discussing the
crisis in the middle east
[Music]
you